right lemon-lime syllabub yes yeah here
we go all funny favourite now here we go
lemon first onto the plate that's on
good man
okay now the idea here just take a whole
possessed nope it okay yeah don't rub it
more than twice in one place like that
Wow I feel on there some pith okay I'll
go over here Janet it's a credit crunch
dinner nice for dessert and all reduce
as well two rubs now I'm a nipple okay
yeah
take the Newports a the nipple lime
exactly the same way as a lemon okay
two rubs nope a round Johnny keep up
are you locking so he's an urban as you
get it the ISIS make sure we got really
nice flavor great okay right all the way
around now yeah from here give that
little tap and that's a lot
you want that they're all that lovely
zest Oh alternative like up cream into
the bowl get a sieve we're going to ship
in the official one catch Johnny's stay
online come on Tommy this is Earth is
amazing yes yes I know I know they cost
less than 60 pence per person yeah in
terms of making a delicious a simple yet
design now eye cream you know creamy
look at my zester yourself are you doing
right I was challenging any pith are you
are you a big desert fan Johnny no I'm
not I've never had luxury suites okay
you're gonna love this one high desert a
grounds of bread and butter
now it was your dream during the meal
housing afterwards well then you cook
laughs lime juice lemon juice pushed
down
okay the singing behind the setup others
get the juice to favor the cream
don't call Venus bossy down from there
keep you sit over there
pass out the juice as not to get any
pips in there yeah cuz base no evil zest
I don't lose my leg come on is it hey
where's your lady where's the long gone
oh where is this where huh as in the
bowl
okay is it true dad still cooks for you
you are yeah yeah me dad does he just
blocks with me [ __ ] huh no mods Bobby
yeah the weight loss succeed so it's a
meal and a ball you don't it was a split
landfill we don't soup is amazing
good liver it is absolutely all kind of
deuteron and the counter whenever the
lag we are we are never shine the kids
once he put it in a norm and they took a
dog offer well we did can't be here MA